impossible is not a fact it's an opinion
impossible this potential and you're at
home watching and you're being called
weird or you're being called different
or whatever the hell you're being called
I'm here tonight to tell you your
critics do not count you know when
you're a kid I think you try so hard to
fit in and when you get older you
realize that fitting in isn't really the
thing that's more interesting need
motivation watch it top ten we believe
nation
he's Justin Timberlake and here's my
take on his top ten rules to success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one impossible is nothing here's
maybe the greatest thing a teen or
anyone in this room and who's watching
on the television at home can learn from
the champ these are words to remember
when anyone tries to tell you to give up
tell you to give in because whatever
you're trying to do is impossible the
champ said this impossible is just a
word thrown around by a small men who
find it easier to live in the world
they've been given than to explore the
power they have to change it impossible
is not a fact it's an opinion impossible
this potential impossible is temporary
impossible is nothing graceful ever
so as a relatively new dad and a former
team I'm here to say you will make
mistakes
along the way you will fall down I have
many times even I'll lead it but what we
do after that fall is how we make
history
because impossible is nothing rule
number two do what you love and
navigated your way here from those early
days in a way a lot of people who
haven't done successfully what do you
attribute that to how did you get out of
the game what was the strategy as we
went solo I don't know they could bring
out a lot of a lot of courage and at the
end of the day you know that you're
getting the opportunity to do what you
love and that's just something that
can't be taken for granted because it
could be different the more you tell
yourself that the more you the more you
look around and you go like isn't this
amazing like isn't this crazy versus I'm
focusing on some sort of outcome because
I have the ability to set unrealistic
expectations not a lot of people they
get to say they have a job that they
love and I appreciate that feel so
humbling and I think you know just
continue to love it just continue to
love it because then you start focusing
on like well you know is this going to
be successful you know redefine what
that means I guess that that's what I'm
trying to do rule number three stay
hungry stay foolish ten years ago a
great innovator named Steve Jobs gave
one of the most inspiring speeches ever
at a college commencement at the end
Steve Jobs quoted some powerful words
he'd seen as a young man that he wanted
to pass on those words were stay hungry
stay foolish now if any of you like
before it saw some of the SNL stuff that
I've done you know I have no issue being
foolish
and anyone who's ever had to deal with
me in person knows that I'm always
hungry literally and figuratively but
that looks crazy there's no way I'm
eating what you guys just put on that
table
that looks like it's been there for like
four hours I'm not I mean it looks it
looks good
anyway so out when I was a teenager I
read some words that I found extremely
powerful that I've been carrying with me
ever since and those words were from our
26th President of the United States
Theodore Roosevelt so just indulge me
for a second it is not the critic who
counts not the man who points out how
the strong man stumbles or where the
doer of Deeds could have done them
better the credit belongs to the man who
is actually in the arena whose face is
marred by dust and sweat and blood who
strives valiantly who airs who comes
short again and again because there is
no effort without error and shortcoming
but who does all always actually strive
to do the deeds who knows great
enthusiasms the great devotions who
spends himself in a worthy cause Who at
the best knows in the end the triumph of
high achievement and who at the worst if
he fails at least fails while daring
greatly so that his place shall never be
with those cold and timid souls who
neither know victory nor defeat so
[Applause]
if you're a young person
like I used to be if you're a young
person like I used to be and you're at
home watching and you're being called
weird or you're being called different
or whatever the hell you're being called
I'm here tonight to tell you your
critics do not count their words will
fade you won't stay foolish stay hungry
dream work hard and who knows maybe
someday you'll find yourself standing on
a stage and maybe someday somebody will
be giving you an award calling you an
innovator rule number four model the
Masters but I also grew up watching
people like Paul McCartney you know and
and and what Michael did for performing
in general is that something that's what
you're talking about it's like stage
performance on stage why we really fell
in love with Michael it was because he
he just like it wasn't even about
captivating you like he did something to
your blood when he performed on stage um
but there was always a thing about him
on stage where you like you can't touch
that yeah like you can't you can't
that's what made it so that's what made
it so grandiose mm-hmm and then you mix
that with people like Paul McCartney who
have you seen him race enough I'm so
much like 70 yeah I thought what the
Grammys when they did okay the guys like
70 any plays for like three hours
stadiums any and it's like you feel like
you're in his living room and he the
only pause between songs is like so he
can put a different guitar on or you
know get down on the piano and he talks
but he has people laughing in the crowd
and and so when you think about those
two sides of being on stage that's what
I grew up yeah idolizing so that's
something that I've always wanted to
incorporate so when you go you know when
it's about you know a song like senorita
mm-hmm it's like I only want to play the
end of the song because this is a song
everybody can sing to each other and you
can feel like you know it feels like a
black party all of a sudden and so those
are always the two things that I know
that I was able to pick
pick up on when I was younger like those
my favorite too and they're both on the
opposite ends of the spectrum when you
really break it down like that but those
are my two favorite things to do as a
show is to make people go like damn yeah
and then to make people go like you know
what I'm having fun yeah you know like
those two things also if you want to
learn how to have more confidence check
out my 254 series they're free the links
aren't a description below for some odd
reason I wanted to kind of go back to
square one and just do it as we done it
in the Beatles as soon as I graduated
high school I wanted to take the next
step
rule number five serve others service to
others is the rent you pay for your room
here on earth so be generous be kind be
fair
it's not just the right thing to do it's
the good thing to do and I think we I
think we all can agree that with all the
tension in the world today that can
divide us we should be part of the
solution and not part of the problem and
you don't you don't have to make a
difference on a global stage you can
volunteer in your neighborhood or in
another neighborhood nearby where people
might look a little different from you
and they might teach you a thing or two
rule number six don't get caught in the
rat race I meet a ton of people and have
met a ton of people along the way and my
time in the music industry
which started when I was very young and
there's the there is the the sort of the
Malcolm Gladwell 10,000 hours theory
about you know you're not you can't
consider yourself an expert or anything
until you've had sort of 10,000 hours at
it and and Wow
while I you know I obviously I agree
with practice there's many people that
spend that much time and and somehow
never get hurt I think T Bone can can
attest to that as well that you meet so
many different talented people along the
way that that for some reason or other
don't get heard so I I've been in the
right place and met the wrong people
I've been in the wrong place and met the
right people and usually the second one
ends up being you know the thing that
can can can catapult I guess someone's
career but I would I would argue that
and I think it's happening more and more
that I think there's a lot of analysis
now there's a lot of like analytics on
what might be success in what might be
failure and I I think for
for those of us who kind of spawned
something out of an idea whether it be
you know a focusing or getting beaten up
in an alley or an idea for a song or
painting or what-have-you I don't know
that that I would measure the success or
failure of it by how its perceived
because once it's done it's just sort of
out there and you have to let it live in
the ether I think the ones that that
I've come to know that have had lasting
success in any field have been the ones
that understand that and can actually
let it go and just continue to be
inspired the same way that you were when
you came up with the idea for the movie
or the song or the or the painting or
what have you so I think that would
probably be the most important thing is
to not get caught up in the rat race of
what might be perceived a certain way
rule number seven find your confidence
the first real seed of debt was this
song I had written called gone it ended
up on our third and last album and it
was the first time I kind of cut by
myself and then brought it to the guys
and included them so we were having an
A&R meeting for the third NSYNC album at
that time and and I said well I have
this other song but I originally wrote
it for Michael I originally wrote that
song for Michael Jackson I just got word
that it wasn't you know that they had to
turn the song down so we decided to cut
it but it was one of those songs where
it felt a little more personal to me
because I had written it for like
biggest artist of all time I guess
Michael did hear it and call me on the
phone and said he wanted to cut the
record but he wanted it to be a duet
between himself and I and I said well
it's already out you know we've already
cut this song as an NSYNC record I'm on
the phone I'm literally punching myself
in the face because I said I can't do
that could we do like NSYNC featuring
Michael Jackson or Michael Jackson
featuring and sinking he was very
absolute about the fact that he wanted
it to be a duet between himself and I
and I think it's the first idea that I
ever got about doing something on my own
because it was the first time I'd ever
really felt the confidence to do it and
I knew that the music that I was
interested in and was writing at the
time was was was different than what we
had previously done and it felt like a
real departure I never told anybody that
Michael's story rule number eight be
different the thing about life that that
if I could tell a young person is
everything that you get picked on or you
feel makes you weird is is essentially
what's gonna make you sexy as an adult
exactly because
I
I just you know I mean
I I got a big nose but I rock it no I I
seriously though I you know everything
you know when you're a kid I think you
try so hard to fit in and when you get
older you realize that fitting in isn't
really the thing that's more interesting
you know being your own person and being
an individual I would not be here if I
would have listened to the kids who told
me I was a terrible singer and I was a
[ __ ] and you know other things that
they would say to me you know it's be
different be different rule number nine
stay grounded I was 14 when when I was
in NSYNC and we got a record deal and we
were going to travel all over the world
and I just remember my mom always
instilling those thoughts in me that you
know at the beginning of the day we all
put our pants on the same way you know
that that just like she said don't let
what you do define who you are and rule
number 10 the last one before a very
special bonus clip is have fun
[Music]
I'm just excited to be singing a Justin
sing song
this is so cool he's my idol so biggest
thing I said in my heart now I'm looking
at the other half of me cuz I don't
wanna lose her now
I'm sorry I'm looking right at the other
half of me as big as it sat in my heart
[Music]
[Music]
reflection proceeds no great need to be
in the my god meeting an icon while
you're singing his song loved him since
I was 11 so this is a really big deal to
me don't cry
[Music]
now I've got a special bonus cut from
Justin on how to make yourself proud
that I think you're really gonna enjoy
but before that except for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to taking
action here we go question number one
who are three masters that you are going
to model number two how can you better
serve others and number three what will
you do today to build your confidence
when I go in the room I really just
think man how do I make the most
beautiful thing I can make how do I make
the thing I could be most proud of how
do I make a song that makes me feel
something inside and makes me proud to
be able to sing it I feel that every
time I go in there and I know that the
label wants a certain thing but I I
can't let it infect my mind right I have
to just go in there and do what feels
right and if I do that I feel like I'll
find a way to sell it we'll sell it
we'll figure it out
yeah but as long as I'm in love with it
and feel free in that room then we're
just gonna come out fine I'm gonna
essentially you have to sell it to
yourself mm-hmm right and that's I think
that's probably the the battle we all go
through because whether you like it or
not you're going to analyze as you're
doing it after you don't like you said I
need a minute to sit with it because I
would felt great in the moment but maybe
I come back to it tomorrow I'm like well
let me just tinker with this or let me
just and so yeah I mean what is it the
quote money can't buy you happiness but
a pace for the pursuit which is great
which is a great comedic you know like a
comical way of looking at it but at the
end of the day like it really can't buy
it for you you know you have to you have
to access that on your own
if you want to see Timbaland's top ten
rules check out the video right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there when you got a sour face you can
finally groove in one of my cuz I got
the feeling I got the soul in my music
took us a long time to get we didn't
come here overnight we had to go through
levels of